other people can learn from writers life
many things because the writers lives
are so different
some are possessed it's something that
comes from outside some are processed
with their visions likes of me are
different I work like a clerk and then
also my books are more like Fresco's and
epic so I start from a corner and
continue and continue without even
knowing what the final picture will be
in the end 40 years of devotion to the
art of the novel taught me one thing
that is to pay attention to people's
lives to pay attention what you hear
about people's lives this novel as
strangers in my mind is based on
interviews that I did with lots of
people that that also taught me to be
modest about people's life and play
around with the details of their lives
till it really sounds more real than
reality most of my life I did not have a
proper editor since I was writing in
Istanbul I am my own editor but the
secret of writing is rewriting self
editing the editing reading to your
beloved ones to your wife to your
daughter to a partner and hearing the
story from other people's point of view
never giving up your high standard of
criteria of good writing but continuing
and on and on and on and on and editing
and editing and caretaking out no matter
how much time you gave to that beautiful
page perhaps that can also be cut out